- Hi, I'm Poppy, do you want
to see something interesting?
- What the?
Hi, I'm Stryker
- Hi Stryker, why are you here?
- I'm pretty sure
you materialized me
with your special glitter,
but I can't remember.
- Oh, are you in a band?
- No, I'm not that cool.
I'm a DJ.
- Why aren't you wearing
a silly helmet like
all the other Djs?
- I'm not that kind
of DJ, I'm a real DJ,
I'm a disc jockey.
- Oh wow, like on the radio?
- Yeah, exactly!
I talk into a microphone,
I get to interview
interesting people.
- Don't you think people
should be able to see you?
If people could see
what you look like,
you would be a lot more famous.
- Poppy, yes, what an
interesting and remarkable
idea you have.
- You should take a lot more
selfies, then you wouldn't
have to work so hard anymore.
- Where have you been
the last 23 years?
I have been doing it
wrong the entire time!
(photos snapping)
- Oh you're doing great.
- Hey, I think I got this.
- You got it Stryker, now
you know what it's like
to have a completely
neutral attitude and outlook
on our meaningless existence.